sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren erst mal möchte ich
mich bedanken frau präsidentin für
unsere gedenkstunde hier und ihre worte
für michael gorbatschow vielen dank
dafür ich glaube es war wichtig hier
notwendig dieses signal an diesem tag
auch zu senden und damit die
parlamentsdebatte zu eröffnen und meine
damen und herren ja wir streiten und wir
ringen heute im parlament zwischen den
demokratischen kräften
über die frage was sind die richtigen
maßnahmen was sind die lösungen sehen
die einen versäumnisse und die anderen
sehen wir tun was aber eins eint uns an
diesem morgen
das nämlich klar ist dass wir als
demokratinnen und demokraten
zusammenstehen gegen die rattenfänger
von rechts und wenn es einen eines
beweises bedurft heute der beitrag von
alles weiden und und das video das
gerade durch social media läuft da
wünscht sich der milch ein teil der
fraktion der afg dass es noch hertha
kommt dass es noch schlimmer wird dass
die krise sich manifestiert damit sie
als ard mit ihren lügen ihrer propaganda
und ihrer menschenfeindlichkeit eine
chance für das anwachsen der ard sehen
und meine damen und herren egal woher
märz herr scholz oder britta haßelmann
stehen das werden die demokratischen
kräfte im land verhindern und darüber
bin ich froh
meine damen und herren wir führen hier
eine inhaltlich sehr kontroversen
debatte in krisenzeiten und herr merz
ich wünsche mir dass ein blick auf die
wirklichkeit der ist zwingend notwendig
den sollten sie sich aufstellen
wer meine damen und herren hat uns in
diese zementierte abhängigkeit geführt
ja der krieg putins auf die ukraine
heute ist nach 196 tagen ist die
situation für die menschen so
schrecklich so dramatisch so
zerstörerisch das für uns feststehen
muss dass die solidarität
uneingeschränkte unsere unterstützung
humanitär wirtschaftlich und auch mit
waffen die sie dringend brauchen dass
wir die als deutscher bundestag
garantieren und die ukraine wissen ihr
seid nicht allein gelassen euch nicht im
stich das ist dass sie gleich aber wie
und das ist die krise aus der viele
andere krisen erwachsen ich denke oft an
das leid die zerstörung für die menschen
in der ukraine
aber wer hat uns in diese zementierte
abhängigkeit von russland geführt von
fossilen energien da sagt doch gerade
eine rot-grüne ich glaube ich spinne
leute der bilder besitzen sie eigentlich
sie haben 16 jahre regiert und wir
wissen dass sie es waren die den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien blockiert
haben wo sie nur konnten wir haben alles
getan auf bundesebene
und auf landesebene da wo sie
regierungsmehrheiten hatten um den
ausbau der erneuerbaren um
energieeffizienz energieeinsparung um
moderne technologien die uns daran
hindern weiterhin in die energie in die
atmosphäre zu schneidern co2 auszustoßen
und dagegen was zu tun das ist ihre
verantwortung 16 jahre unionsgeführte
regierung und tat sie das wo allgemein
nie glauben wollen helfe ich ihm
gedankenstütze wer hat eigentlich dafür
gesorgt dass der gasspeicher 20 15 20 15
an gazprom ging das war ihr
bundeswirtschaftsminister
es war die verantwortung von altmaier
die uns dahin geführt hat meine damen
und herren und wer hat bis zuletzt die
letzte bundesregierung hat bis zuletzt
am ostring zwei festgehalten auch diese
große fehler entscheidung ist eine
entscheidung die sie gemeinsam zu
verantworten haben während wir davor
gewarnt haben auch daran erinnert sich
heute wirklich nicht gerne jemand und
die rufe aus ihrer fraktion für ein gas
embargo soll ich ihnen die
presseberichte zeigen vermehrt sich
standen doch in der ersten reihe dabei
ich bin froh dass wir das nicht getan
haben wo wären wir denn heute in der
krisenbewältigung
er wollte was müssen wir den menschen
zumuten wenn wir uns auf dieses auf
diese vielen entscheidungen kollege
hängen gelassen die kollegen auslassen
keiner zeit
und ihre ideologische debatten führungen
mit blick auf atom die ist doch
entlarven meine damen und herren da sagt
hier einer mit großen augen nein wir
sind auch nicht für die verlängerung von
atomlaufzeiten kommt im fünften satz
aber so drei bis vier jahre oder
vielleicht bis zum ende der energiekrise
herr merz wissen sie eigentlich was das
heißt das heißt die verlängerung der
atomenergie das heißt den ausstieg vom
ausstieg den hatten sie doch schon mal
hinter sich denn sie wissen doch dass
mit nein ganz es fakt und sie sollten
sich damit beschäftigen denn drei bis
vier jahre halten die brennstäbe
überhaupt nicht sie müssten neue 3 stell
besorgen und damit sind wir beim
ausstieg aus dem ausstieg und der ist
uns schon mal einmal teuer gekommen
gerade wegen ihnen und ihrer viele
entscheidungen in der regierungszeit 29
bis 23 10 meine damen und herren kaum
eine debatte wird so fakten frei geführt
wie diese der stresstest der
stresstest der polizei zeigt ganz
eindeutig er rechtfertigt keine
verlängerung der atomenergie und das ist
gut so meine damen und herren es handelt
sich um eine hochrisikotechnologie
wir haben den auftrag und zwar
gesetzlich und auch durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit auf den weg
gegeben dass wir uns um die gefahren für
die bürgerinnen und bürger sorgen machen
müssen und was nicht geht ist dass sie
weiterhin lamentieren und polemisieren
und solche primitiven formeln wie drei
+3 +3 von anti scheuer aus bayern auch
noch ernsthaft in die debatten hier ein
türen hier andreas scheuer aus der csu
ist dafür dass wir drei neue
kernkraftwerke bauen das soll ein
beitrag zur krisenbewältigung im hier
und jetzt sein wissen sie wie lange ein
bau eines atomkraftwerkes dauert
offenbar nicht aber bis bayern hat sich
das sich rumgesprochen der mann hat ja
auch nur verantwortungen dafür
irgendwelche dinge in die welt zu pusten
aber sonst nichts auf die endlager frage
gibt es keine antwort trage nicht von
cdu und csu
außerdem satz nur nicht in bayern meine
damen und herren und lässt lassen sie
uns zu den fakten zurück kommen wir
holen jetzt nach was jahrelang versäumt
wurde dass nämlich die priorität auf dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren der
energieeinsparung der in denen die
effizienz liegen und daher reicht es
auch mit ihrem polemisieren gegen robert
habeck denn wer allen voran an der
spitze hat gerade verdammt viel zu tun
und leistet viele und ich rate und das
spricht doch aus jeder pore
aus jeder pore spricht doch der neid
wenn ich höre dass manche sagen es täte
manchen gut
ich finde es täte manchen von ihnen gut
erst zu denken dann zu sprechen
meine damen und herren wir
haben jetzt drei entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht und das ist doch
wirklich wichtig und notwendig denn wir
können doch nicht sagen wie weit wir
jetzt sind wie sich die krise weiter
entwickeln wird es wird viele menschen
habt treffen in unserem land das wissen
wir und wir sind längst nicht am ende
mit diesen unterstützungs paketen wir
sind ihnen krisenmodus ja und wir werden
vieles tun müssen sozial abfedern in
erneuerbare energien investieren und die
ökologische und soziale transformation
der wirtschaft weiter begleiten und
werde heute so tut als wäre die eine
maßnahme das richtige und damit wäre
alles getan streut den menschen doch
sank in die augen wir können doch nur
das signal ausgehen wir nehmen ihre
sorgen ängste war wir wissen viele
menschen haben angst vor abstieg und vor
armut und wir fiel dann das ab und ob
wir und ob wir in zwei monaten mehr tun
müssen weitere dinge auf den weg bringen
müssen das wird sich zeigen das weiß
heute noch niemand weil noch niemand
weiß wohin die krise noch geht und wie
tief sie greifen wird und deshalb ist es
wichtig das signal auszusenden
wir bauen die soziale ökologische
transformation der ausbau der
erneuerbaren mit kraft wir machen uns
unabhängig was jahrelang versäumt wurde
in sachen energieversorgung wir
versuchen gemeinsam mit wirtschaft
handwerk und dem mittelstand
die ja ja ja wir tun alles dafür in
dieser krise zu stabilisieren und darum
geht es im moment und wir machen jetzt
in dieser woche die
haushaltsplanberatungen die auch ein
klares signal geben auf die frage wohin
wollen wir investieren dann geht es auch
nicht nur um die nationalen tragen es
geht auch um die internationale
verantwortung die wir haben klimaschutz
umwelt natur
entwicklungszusammenarbeit humanitäre
hilfe für die krise all das ist
notwendig und hier ist jede
kraftanstrengung notwendig wenn wir nach
pakistan sehen wenn wir die
hitzeentwicklung in diesem sommer in
europa ansehen auch hier bei uns dann
wissen wir was sie uns hinterlassen
haben nämlich lauter baustellen die wir
jetzt im hinblick auf die bekämpfung der
krise der klimakrise angehen müssen und
sie zeigen sich in so einer dramatik
dass wir auch im rahmen des haushaltes
hier akzente setzen müssen die unsere
internationale und nationale
verantwortung deutlich unter 34 das ist
wichtig und gleichzeitig es mit dem
dritten entlastungspaket ein signal
gesendet dass wir menschen hier im land
die wenig haben
das wird die zielgenau unterstützen
wollen und gehen sie nicht so darüber
hinweg ja ich höre kritik allgemein am
entlastungspaket wo sind sie denn mit
ihrer verantwortung beim thema
bürgergeld bei den menschen die wenig
haben wir machen die größte
regelsatzerhöhung die es seit einführung
von haupt stier gibt und das ist der
erste schritt wir machen gleichzeitig
das wohngeld den heizkostenzuschuss die
frage von energiepreis pauschale alles
wichtige soziale alles wichtige soziale
abfederung sie werden dazu beitragen
dass sich not lindert natürlich bleibt
es dabei dass viele menschen in einer
kritischen situation sind und wir werden
immer wieder überlegen ob die maßen
haben die die auf den weg bringen
reichen oder ob wir noch nachsteuern
müssen wie zb beim kleinen handwerk ob
die bäckereien fleischereien oder der
kulturszene wir müssen doch gemeinsam
als parlament das signal aussenden wir
lassen euch nicht im stich wir überlegen
uns immer wieder wo können wir ansetzen
was können wir tun und dass es
verantwortliches handeln meine damen und
herren
und weil ich gerade über die gesprochen
habe die wenig haben
ich finde es im inntal wie markus söder
auf kosten von beifall im bierzelt beim
gillamoos über menschen gesprochen hat
die wenig geld haben und den
grundsicherung leben mein eindruck ist
sie kennen diese lebenswirklichkeit von
menschen die arm sind überhaupt nicht
ansonsten ja ich glaube schon ich habe
lange genug als sozialarbeiterin
gearbeitet
ich glaube dass markus söder damit ein
zeichen ausgesendet hat ihm ist jedes
mittel recht zur parteipolitischen
profilierung
profilieren und sei es auf dem rücken
von menschen die arm sind die wenig
haben und das finde ich in form dass
sowas
mit sowas der wahlkampf eingeläutet wird
demnächst vor sich haben ich finde das
unzulässig aber vielleicht muss es jeder
für sich verantworten was er da tut aber
die abwertung von menschen ist ein
mittel dem wir uns gemeinsam wirklich
sagen sollte das ist nicht unser ding
und das tun wir nicht keine waren ich
glaube wir stehen gerade in wirklich
schwierigen zeiten niemand wird sagen
durch die ein oder andere maßnahme ist
die krise vorbei wir versuchen alles wir
geben alles krisenbewältigung zu machen
den ausbau der erneuerbaren
voranzubringen und uns unabhängig zu
machen und wir nehmen unsere
internationale verantwortung wahr weil
wir wissen nur gemeinsam sind wir stark
in dieser zeit die zeitenwende sozial
und nachhaltig gestalten darum geht es
jetzt meine damen und herren vielen dank